de mal en peor así es como va la semana
del presidente de eeuu joe biden la
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses
de afganistán ha generado polémica
polémica agudizada por el atentado en el
aeropuerto de kabul donde murieron más
de 10 soldados americanos y decenas de
afganos
tú sabes perder a un hijo una hija un
esposo una esposa es como que tu pecho
se ha succionado a un hueco negro y 15
es que no hay una salida te preguntas
qué está pasando así que mi corazón
nuestros corazones están con todas las
personas que hemos perdido
además la corte suprema de mayoría
conservadora suspendió el moratorio a la
dicción impuesto durante la pandemia por
lo que millones de hogares podrían
enfrentar un desalojo esto en medio de
un aumento de contagios por la llegada
de la variante delta
las personas que están seriamente sin
hogar si tienen trabajos pero sus
trabajos no les pagan lo suficiente para
pagar alquiler en que ha estado de este
país se puede obtener el primer y último
depósito de seguridad de 725 dólares la
hora cero entonces disipemos toda esta
otra mitología sobre la pereza y la
criminalidad y todas estas cosas
y esta misma corte suprema- reanudó el
programa de trump permanecer en mexico
la medida obliga a los solicitantes de
asilo a esperar en mexico mientras se
procesa su petición de residencia en los
tribunales estadounidenses
con 49% de aprobación la tasa más baja
desde que inició su mandato bardem se
enfrentará a retos aún mayores la
próxima semana se prevé el 31 de agosto
como fecha límite de las evacuaciones y
la retirada de los últimos soldados
estadounidenses de afganistán